[Music]
hi my name is dwayne joseph olsen and i
have a youtube channel called dwayne
made it on which i do custom art
projects prop replicas and restorations
this doll is an f b doll according to my
research it's a marianne f b doll which
was one of the bigger doll companies
back in the early part of the 20th
century
they were significantly popular
especially because
a lot of their earlier dolls were the
first to do realistic proportions
[Music]
i'm making small incisions to open up
the seams and begin to dismantle the
doll piece by piece
[Music]
i'm slowly loosening up the
old glue that attaches the head to the
body
removing the head
[Music]
[Music]
at this point i'm able to turn my
attention to some of the features that
help me to actually identify
what this doll is supposed to look like
i can see that the mouth plate has four
teeth so i know to only look at f and b
dolls that have four teeth the doll has
eyelashes on the top not the bottom so i
know to only look at dolls with top
lashes and the doll has eyebrows that
are solid gold crescents
so that'll help me to figure out both
the doll that this once was and what
color hair i'm going to be looking at
later on in the process
[Music]
once i've got the whole doll dismantled
i can begin removing the paint and going
through starting with the legs using a
moderate grade sandpaper and going over
the whole piece
i also want to make sure that i'm not
sanding away any of the features so
going through as gently and carefully as
i can removing all that paint
looking at the face of the doll you can
actually tell just how much this doll
was used whoever had this doll
definitely loved it a lot
[Music]
the biggest problem with
this doll is the cracks
i'm taking some wood filler and starting
to find those cracks
particular wood filler is pink in color
but a lot like school glue sticks it
actually dries clear
something that i found while dismantling
it but there was a voice box in there
this particular voice box is called the
cryer because that's the sound that it
makes there's a little cloth membrane
that's been oiled inside and every time
the voice box gets turned upside down
that compresses and it forces the air
through the instrument part of the voice
box
i just have to take a piece of cloth and
replace this membrane
[Music]
the eyes are actually in pretty good
shape the only problem is the paint is
severely discolored i'm going to go
ahead and use some white rust-oleum
spray paint and cover those guys up
i could tell that these were once a
bright blue but they had faded to kind
of a dark teal almost then i actually
went on my laptop and i
photoshopped some irises i print out
those irises on water slide decal paper
soak them in a little bit of water and
apply them like you would a normal decal
and once the eyes are ready i can go
ahead and pop them back into the head
now i can begin the painting process i'm
taking paint and i'm watering it down to
kind of a milk like consistency pouring
it into the airbrush
[Music]
once the initial coat of her flesh tone
is done i can go through and start to
blush the areas i know i want blushed
in this case it's the cheeks and the
knees and a little bit of the hands
once all the airbrushing is done and dry
i can go in and repaint the lips
[Music]
i'm using a black watercolor pencil here
[Music]
once the eyelashes are sketched i mix up
a shade of paint that closely resembles
the
color that these brows once were
and going through with a very thin brush
and repainting the brows
[Music]
the doll does have painted eyelashes but
it also has a set of
literal eyelashes that get glued onto
the lid
i'm actually just using a set of fake
eyelashes that you would get at a beauty
shop trimming those down to the right
shape and gluing them on with super glue
[Music]
once that's done i can begin the
reassembly process
with all that taken care of i can
finally restuff the doll
i'm just gonna stick the crier back in
there
before gluing on the head
i was able to find only one picture of
what the original f and b mariandoll was
supposed to look like
after making a trip to the fabric store
and finding as close of fabrics as i
could with all the pieces traced out i
can begin cutting them and piecing them
together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a wig that i ordered on etsy
it's from the 50s i'm just going to glue
it onto the head
while that glue is setting up i'm going
to work on making the iconic fnb heart
fmb dolls either came with a heart
bracelet or a heart necklace
this particular one according to the
picture has the heart necklace
i could only find a reproduction
bracelet so what i'm going to do is take
the original chain out of the bracelet
trim a new chain place the bracelet
heart on the new chain and use that
and with that the piece is complete
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you